why did you say it again but you sound
so southern i i want to do my own style
of helpful advice with bobby and kalylla
old hustler rashford
bobby and
klylo
i want to hear this george you do it
unhelpful
[Laughter]
i've ever heard god try it go deeper
dude you got to go deep he went higher
you have no base to your voice you have
nobody at all is mine good though yeah
you get you're pretty low yeah pretty
good on helpful advice
on helpful advice with
bobby and cloyle
advice
with bobby
[Laughter]
why are you making me do that because i
love it
finish it start from the top okay
i'm sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
i want everyone on video to watch her
face while she does it you look so what
did you contour your face yeah
this is your neck so this is your neck
oh so yeah yeah oh like a turtle oh god
that was so good
next question gilbert
hi simply put i've dropped out of a
college after trying to graduate for
four years i work a part-time job but
i'm still semi and uh semi-dependent on
my strict asian parents who are
insistent on keeping me on finishing my
degree
no how can i break no how do i break the
news to them
no not be graduating and how do i find
your direction
man i'm [ __ ] listen to me right now
okay his name is peter i don't give a
[ __ ] bro
all right
my parents my brother and i
changed them
they try to change us
oh you have to go to college oh you have
to be an engineer you have to do no nope
we're going to do drugs
all right we're going to [ __ ] you know
we're gonna do what we want
and then you know what they did they go
oh okay i guess
over time what are they gonna do either
cut us off right or accept our lifestyle
why am i gonna [ __ ] go to college for
you mom
because i don't know how to do it i
don't know i've never read a book before
i've never read
i don't know anything
all right so it's like no just let me
finish let me finish okay let me [ __ ]
finish all right so i don't didn't
really even listen to the thing halfway
through it i just reacted i know you did
it but i want to just say this okay this
is that
you can change them
let me tell you something right now i
know a comic by the name i'm not gonna
even say his name
but i know a comic he was an engineer he
was making six figures a year he's a
great comic he happens to be
middle eastern
right it has nothing to do with but his
dad's very strict his dad wants him
still be an engineer but this kid has so
much talent he just can't
it would be a shame to the world for him
not to do it right so he chose comedy
all right he's
he's doing well
he's making a living and his dad still
he doesn't like it and he is you know
but what is he going to do
do what his dad does
this is your life
if my kid
if kaleila and i didn't kill babies
we would have probably a couple
why do you keep accusing me
we didn't kill anybody aren't you glad
we don't have one with this new
president i know but
please don't say that oh please don't
say that but what i'm gonna say this is
this is that if my child goes hey
dad
i'm gonna be a
i'm gonna make
clogs
what
yeah that's why i'm going to clog making
school
and i'll be like
whatever okay
that's what my son or daughter does
you know i want them to be you know a
professional soccer player or whatever
my dream is for my child to be like i
want you to be
you know um either soccer player or in
the mma or whatever right but if they
want to do something that i didn't
envision that's their life
okay and i just i i spent too many years
fighting with my parents like oh your
cousin cholla she's going to harvard at
dinner table and then trying to make me
feel like [ __ ]
because i didn't go to college
you know i i you know i i remember
report card good days
i knew that if i brought home my report
card to my parents that it was 100 i'm
gonna get beat
so one time i think was my sophomore
year in high school there's a cl we
lived on a gigantic kind of mountain not
a mountain but like you know it was
uphill fancy country club it wasn't okay
it was a nice community
but you could go into like the woods and
there was like a little cliff that you
could jump up you'd die right i remember
one time i had my report card in my hand
and i was on the cliff and i was going
to jump off
jesus because i would rather kill myself
than to face my parents because i got a
couple of c's and a d on a report card
but i would always come home with my
report card and they i would get the
beating i would cry i'd be in my room
and then i would do drugs
but my point is is this is that at the
end of the day
you know my parents
i'm very glad that i chose my career but
that's the exception to the rule not
everybody who says [ __ ] you mom i'm not
going to college makes the amount of
money you do now as a comedian so no
it's not about i didn't say money i
didn't say money what i'm saying is is
that you know as soon as i started doing
stand-up and did what i wanted to do
number one it gave me imagine not going
to college and you have no skills
you don't you're lazy you don't want to
work
and you're like what the [ __ ] do i do
right so if i'm gonna struggle in life
and i'm gonna
be broke i might as well do something
that i enjoy doing
which is i enjoyed performing
and it worked out for me i believe that
if anybody
if people really enjoy what they do and
they do it with passion and with
dedication that inevitably something's
going to happen what does this kid want
to do
oh he wants to go into entertainment
comedy yeah well then do it he has a
plan so that's my thing if if i had a 17
year old tell me like [ __ ] college i'm
just gonna do nothing i'm not gonna take
that as an option you can come to me
with with saying [ __ ] college if you
show me an alternate plan of action if
you say yeah i'm gonna i save this much
money and i'm gonna travel for two years
and i'm gonna figure [ __ ] out when i
come back okay fine that's fine with me
if you say i'm taking this i'm moving to
la and i'm gonna you know i'm not gonna
need your financial support i'm gonna
work as in a restaurant and try to make
it in the business that's fine now if
you come with me and you say i don't
know what i'm going to do but i need you
to support me financially [ __ ] you kid
[ __ ] no
that's not acceptable you're going to
college no you know what i mean like and
you're going to figure out
sometime while you're over there what
you want to do
but in the meantime no you don't get to
sit around and do nothing
you know no i ran into this problem when
only six years ago my parents
so if people don't know i actually
dropped out of school but i remember
when i had to tell my parents i was
going to move to chicago i'm going to do
comedy i'm going to be an actor
uh i came so i'm so so afraid to tell my
parents i did in a restaurant a public
place just so i know i wouldn't get hit
by a chair i made sure i was surrounded
by people in a japanese restaurant yeah
how did you tell them so they were
eating sushi and i literally was like so
my mom's probably laughing listen to
this i was so scared mom and dad
probably 19 18 maybe 19
i had a i made a powerpoint presentation
i printed it out
i'll tell you why i did that because i
heard emma stone did it for her mom then
i forgot she did it to her white mother
who was like okay
so i was like my parents are going to do
that
i took it out i just as soon as i took
out the papers i said
yeah so i have this dream i want to act
and i think i should stop school i just
pushed it i didn't make eye contact with
my mom my dad
and my dad was like hmm
aydah i had a california roll yeah
but then put that away
and my mom would even look at me so
eventually worked out something where
like i couldn't be rebellious and just
run away that's just not how i am with
my family i know some people can do that
i worked out something where i say okay
i'll go to community college
i did that but basically i just
[ __ ] it like [ __ ] it i just [ __ ]
around just bought time for you
while i was in chicago doing all that
stuff and eventually i had to prove it
to my parents so they didn't really talk
to me for almost two or three years it
was like on and off yeah awkward
relationship they came to chicago saw me
one week where i was in five shows back
to back with a full packed out audience
saw the shows flew back to atlanta i got
calls from them individually
where they were like
we get it yeah and after that they're
like if you're gonna do it do it right
move to la i get the same exact thing
when i did the tonight show
yeah i was at a 40-seat theater yeah it
wasn't
a 40-seat live show live show yeah it
was jay leno that's fine
the same principle though the both
stories
wow
but mine was that was a great story
sucked
40 shows in front of [ __ ] coffee shop
you are the korean trump
nothing wow you guys can't
say that again
you're the korean trump okay we're done
there's for tonight
okay that's hurt tell me
tell me another glorious story of yours
why are you attacking me
i was just
brothers
hey guys all of you rock especially
bobby there we go i have a bit of a
problem so let's get into it basically
i'm a liar i lie to my friends family
friends strangers and maybe even to
myself it always starts small but
snowballs which i recognize always my
fault but i can't help to stop myself i
find myself craving attention and just
the acceptance that lying about small
things gets me
people seem to like me more think i'm
funnier and more interesting more worth
talking to when i sprinkle in lies to my
stories or personal history
the problem spun out of control last
year when i was still a senior in
university i really admire actors
comedians and artists and i aspire to be
like all of them one day but i don't
seem to have any real talent or at least
not yet i would tell my friends about
going to improv class and attending open
mics but that was all a lie i only went
to comedy introductory class but because
i was too nervous and lazy to push
through the painting i don't know how to
edit these or it's oh it's part of all
of them
figure out that if i have any talent at
all keep going regardless when bobby was
coming to town i lied to the same
university friends and said i was
bobby's opening act
my friends were so excited for me that i
couldn't tell them the truth so i never
did when the show finally came i
basically catfished my friends with
another lie saying that my relative had
gone terminally ill and i had to leave
town i even went so far to tell my
friends that bobby had personally told
me that he understood and was okay with
bailing on him
now i'm in my first year working in a
new city with a new job in corporate
america i'm meeting all sorts of new and
interesting people so the urge to lie
has resurfaced so far i've kept i kept
oh really yeah so far so far i've kept
my lying to a minimum but i've recently
met a girl i really like and desire to
liar her lie to her is huge because i
want her so badly to uh reciprocate the
feelings should i tell this girl about
my lying past how do i stop lying to
people thanks for your help at 24 year
old sleeper oh my god
it's like catch me if you can yeah
that's intense yeah
damn bobby's opening i can i just say
something
i lie a lot as well
do you know that yeah but you fib you
don't you know they're the same thing
but i mean what i'm saying is it doesn't
destroy people's lives you didn't tell
people you were in django unchained i
know but
no but no but give me a movie that i
haven't seen but just ask me if i saw it
oh have you seen the cryptic knight
loved it man that was really good the
lead the lead was incredible he should
get i've never seen that who's the lead
no but that's what i'm saying i lie all
the time okay so i really wanted him to
watch the movie amores perros
and he desperately didn't want to watch
the movie with me i had already seen it
i was like you have to see it you have
to see it
while i was in the bathroom for two
minutes i come back and he was like what
was the movie you wanted to see i was
like
and he was like is it and he goes on to
tell me the whole synopsis of it yeah
and he was like yeah with this and i was
like yeah you're actually right that's
exactly the way he's like oh i already
seen it and it turns out he in that two
minutes that i was in the restroom he
wikipedia the plot that's good i do that
looked at his wife
i really wanted to my buddies like i
said like breaking bad was the best
thing that was ever made until i was
just like you know i really loved it and
i was talking to a buddy of mine and he
said well have you seen the sopranos and
i said that oh that gangster thing from
he was like yeah yeah and he was i was
he was like look here's my um hbo
account sign it and start watching it
yeah so i said it okay
and um whenever somebody like really
pulls something on me like you've got it
oh it's the best it's the best and i'm
always like well i'll give it a shot
then yeah and so i started watching it
and
my wife kayla she's not into really
gangster stuff but i i love i love that
stuff so i start i start um
so like staying up to like five six a.m
and i'm like what the [ __ ] am i i have
things to do in like a few hours but i'd
be staying up and can't like why it's a
good show it's a good show and i said
and i was trying to force her to watch
it with me yeah and she didn't want to
and i said look if you watch this with
me
i'll watch game of thrones with you she
really wanted me to watch game of
thrones and i was like i don't like
magical whatever
magical video yeah and so she's so
that's where that [ __ ] comes from
wherever he's from that magical so
i said well i tell you what okay i'll
watch that if you watch the sopranos
with me we'll watch the sopranos first
and then we'll watch game of thrones
and i
had no intention of watching game of
thrones
are you hearing this for the first time
i know she knows
can i just say this though [ __ ] [ __ ]
face
game of thrones game of thrones is a far
superior superior show over
the sopranos you think i think game of
thrones is one of the best shows ever
made well i am i'm now i have so you
have you watched it all i've watched it
all okay
okay good
i haven't
there's a robot yeah
so yeah so this is the thing i re i i i
have a pattern when it comes to
to reading things i haven't read
i haven't read one story book unless my
mum had read it to me when i was like
five years old yeah
i um i only read factual things and it
kind of appears
you remind me of my brother steve in a
weird way you guys really have that same
dynamic that same like innocent
dynamic and when you talk you're trying
to be real but you're so innocent and
whimsical that it just sounds so [ __ ]
funny
like i would just laugh right in your
[ __ ] stupid face
you're so cute and funny
is that what you like about him
yeah he's so funny yeah yeah thank you
you're welcome and you're oddly polite
in a weird way though i like it like
your brother yeah like my brother you're
just like my brother steve yeah
i would say that you're probably better
not to do those things and don't act
on
because when
the problem you get when you tell a lie
is that eventually the lie will catch up
with you
you can be so good at lying and be great
at it because i'm pretty good at lying
as well but you can be really good at it
but eventually it'll get you it'll bite
in the ass and it's not worth doing it
because at the end of the day you know
you're not achieving anything by you're
lying to yourself
you're lying to yourself more than
anybody and all that praise you're
receiving is not real either no i also
do think that the extent at which you
lie really warrants nice sit down with a
therapist to really dig deep as to why
the pathological
patterns just keep going and there's
something very insecure and broken maybe
from your childhood that makes you feel
like you have to overcompensate and come
up with these fantastical stories that
aren't true and that's
you are hurting a lot of people by doing
that you're going to lose friendships
you're going to
lose a lot of different things in your
life far far more than you you would
think
or
or you can lie to win as bobby does it
or you can lie enough pathologically lie
enough and one day you too can be the
president of the united states
[Music]
the way we end our podcast we do
something called um unhelpful advice so
we have an email somebody has a problem
you can be positive negative or whatever
you want to say okay and then so go
ahead
unhelpful advice with bobby kalila and
burke crasher
hi tiger belly i'm a recent discoverer
of your podcast and have uh over the
past three months caught up in almost
half your episodes i love your podcast
and it brought me to tears of laughter
many times
i'm a white male i grew up in sweden and
moved to us when i was 20 years old in
europe we'd use words like
n-word fly all over the place and it's
not as controversial or personal over
here what does it mean n word yeah i
don't know what that is uh [ __ ] and then
he put a uh something symbol and an a
oh that's not even a hard r just soft a
yeah okay okay
i'm a huge fan of totally acceptable
yeah
[Laughter]
and i would throw it all over the place
until i moved until i moved here in the
states yeah and people problematic
especially black people told me it was
not cool especially
that's weird
shut up all the people is the black
people yeah well they must have a
problem with that word
i'm a man of respect and i stopped using
it though at the time i had friends from
texas used both using both [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and i thought it was okay because
i found those words funny but i
literally branched into them
oh yeah i get it
but i later realized it was not cool and
luckily i didn't get beat up for it now
fast forward seven years
going through the i'm hanging out with a
beater and a chick in it
fast forward like he's got like [ __ ]
i'm missing a broken heart for seven
years uh going through the current uh
political climate and discussion is more
heater than ever
we are seeing okay
we are also seeing consequences when
people use the n-word and uh and
streamers whose audience and teenagers
lose millions of fans just overnight i
married a filipino husband four years
ago
there's a woman a woman
i i guess or it's um
he's a gay swede oh
yeah we're all good
yeah yeah i married my filipino husband
four years ago and during dinner i said
hello my [ __ ]
i was i hope this is a woman i want to
marry her yeah i was thinking that's the
show i'm gonna do i was thinking about
your podcast i was thinking about your
podcast yeah he stared at me and said
don't say that that's not okay and
you'll get beat up i said sorry why
what's so bad googly goo [ __ ]
he laughed and then said it's racist and
very disrespectful towards me and
especially vietnamese people that's why
americans called them that's what
americans called them during the vietnam
war then we got into this whole
conversation about that so my question
to you guys is what what is your concept
uh context of this uh when is it okay to
say
uh should it not be said and
it's for right now just stop it stop it
is it only for asians to say just for
right now right let's just white people
just don't say those things for right
now
the climate might change wait five
months yeah wait a year maybe in five
years it'll it'll settle down but i'll
tell you i'll tell you my perspective as
a white person yeah that's why i don't
say i don't say
uh any of those words i said i said
[ __ ] tonight but i don't say it like i
said alex we were like it's comics
talking yeah and it's a it's a podcast a
little bit like we're [ __ ] around
but i don't say him only reason i told
my daughters about this it gets
comfortable in your mouth so then one
night you say it at a bar and it slides
out and you don't realize you said it
and look if it makes someone feel like
[ __ ] don't make anyone feel like [ __ ]
that's it i don't look i don't care
about your struggle i don't care about
your parents struggle i just don't want
you to feel like [ __ ] like i don't like
that's in the moment i don't i don't
want anyone to feel like [ __ ] wow but uh
but but i i do love this person a tad
bit yeah how beautiful would it be to be
with them their first day in america
when they don't realize this is racist
look at all these no
way
like my family just arrived from the
philippines last week yeah and
it's they don't use the n-word but how
in their way of saying a black person
they use the term negro
which sounds like negro which could be
you know but that's they're not saying
it other than like oh that's a black
person that's how you say it in my
language
and they were you know obviously it's a
culture shock coming from a small town
in the philippines here it's like so
diverse
so they're like oh and she was saying it
like complimentary we were at the
clipper game oh and she's like a
basketball game
oh my god
yeah she was saying deandre jordan was
really handsome but the word negro just
echoed
it's a everything gun
and oh my god like i just like
i was like no no no no no no no
[Music]
i uh i have uh i have asian friends who
have nicknames for black people yeah i
won't i won't i won't out anyone yeah i
guess i already did kind of listen to
the podcast
they have nicknames for black people so
when they say them they say the nickname
and i don't like the nickname because i
feel like people will catch on to it
what is it is it um are they vietnamese
did they say me dang no oh sedums sedums
see them what is that i know that one
sedums
oh
[Laughter]
yeah
but i i said uh
i think that's one of the things that's
like
that's when you know progress is
happening is when you don't want to hear
the nickname
the the not even racist nickname but the
word for the people like when i was
growing up in florida they called black
people canadians
and so they'd be like there are a lot of
canadians there's like a hockey match
going on here
when you turn the corner you're like hey
man don't let can you not say that
because i don't i don't see that the way
you see that yeah like can you not yeah
but uh anyway sweetest guy
yeah sweetest guy good luck good luck
yeah good luck with everything and um
do you guys want more uh one more quick
question yeah go ahead all right this
guy was inspired from kalala the other
week hey tiger brother i decided to ask
this question after i heard the story of
kalila confronting the guys who accused
her of profiling a couple months ago i
was walking down the street at night and
i noticed a middle aged woman walking in
front of me she kept looking back at me
uncomfortably she began uh walking
quicker
i felt really offended that she was
scared of me i ran fast until i caught
up with her
sorry
huffing and out of breath and said yo i
don't want to rape you
she was mortified and sped away
walked away
wait wait is this wrong i was trying to
stick up for myself i'm a 20 year old
white guy medium weight medium height
medium white yeah
am i guilty until proven innocent for
the rest of my life how do i confront
people who make these assumptions i
don't want to be spideless either i have
a i emailed you the picture of who he is
yeah
oh my gosh i hate people like that well
he was trying you influenced him to
stick up for himself good for you what's
his name his name is maximus that's his
name well also it's a little cute pony
in his picture let me see him see so
this guy ran up to the woman oh
basically i'm gonna see this photo
this is what generally tiger belly fans
look like
in terms of white dudes right this is
basically
like just a
carrot top doug stanhope you know hybrid
he's so cute he's so cute so if you if
you saw this man cloud behind you and
you kept you looked back once and he ran
towards you faster i will giggle yo i
don't want to rape you would you be
scared
um okay are you a prop comic
that's what it looks like are you at the
flamingo
i would be frightened if you ran after
me for sure yeah right don't do that
dude yeah don't do that
but but also like i i'm so sad that i
inspired that yeah
don't be angry at the lady and say yo i
don't want to be also because
she probably didn't assume you were
going to rape her she probably thought
like something less than that like hey
he's gonna steal my purse or whatever
the rape was a little excessive it's a
little excessive yeah so don't like yeah
influence you too much in your decisions
uh what a great podcast today
that shannon in the clam song is called
um did you love me
what a great podcast
what a fun joy i'm gonna go eat with
steve is that okay
why do you have to ask me also because i
always want to know
yes
can you help me with my oil when we come
back okay yeah i gotta go